la vie de l'artiste numérique alexis la
fontaine aux bascules et récemment ses
oeuvres virtuel se sont vendus en ligne
pour plus de six cent mille dollars
des sculptures numérique inspiré par ses
pairs je n'ai vraiment mis de l'avant
puis ironiquement salle comme changé ma
vie 1 190 ch
il fait du crip thouars ça semble
compliqué mais expliquant le simplement
ses oeuvres sont liés un certificat
d'authenticité numérique appli mft et ce
certificat vaut son pesant d'or il est
sur un réseau public ultra sécurisée qui
garantit la propriété la rareté et la
valeur d'une oeuvre même et tangibles de
plus en plus quand il ya un artiste qui
sort des oeuvres c'est plate forme là ça
gênant quand même des gros chiffres
généralement souvent dans les centaines
de millions de dollars
l'engouement est planétaire la maison
d'enchères christie's a fracassé un
record en vendant le certificat nst
d'une oeuvre numérique de l'américain
people pour 69 millions $
l'artiste groves a vendu des oeuvres
totalisant 6 millions de dollars en
quelques heures à peine
les galeries en ligne se multiplient
permettant une reconnaissance bien
méritée selon alexis sais c'est pas un
bouton tout est fait
c'est ainsi plusieurs heures de travail
acharné des années travaillent à
développer une certaine technique un
certain style c'est pas aussi temps
j'aime qu'une peinture par exemple mais
c'est quand même l'artiste
alicia rénovant et collectionne du
territoire un sentiment affectif
le propriétaire d'une heure de la seule
et unique heures il ya des gens pour qui
c'est plus l'investissement par exemple
parce que s'il ya une prise de valeur
cette technologie modifie la façon de
collectionner mais aussi le lien entre
artistes et collectionneurs
on a tendance à plus partagés avec les
collecteurs parce qu'on a un lien direct
avec eux qui te fait à travers les
réseaux sociaux puis les plateformes
j'ai des collectionneurs qui sont très
fiers de leurs galeries et construisent
des aspects de lieu virtuel dans lequel
ils peuvent présenter leurs collections
et appelle manser des musées donc ils
veulent contester en sport le statut
d'une usine actionnaires le cri thouars
se démocratise et devient de moins en
moins critique ici n'est dit alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal